it's day two of pope francis's historic
visit to iraq
he's aiming to rally the country's
minority christian community
whose numbers have dropped significantly
after years of war and persecution
the pope began the day in the holy city
of najaf where he had a private meeting
with one of iraq's most
powerful figures in shia islam the grand
ayatollah ali sistani
a meeting that was months in the making
every detail
carefully planned after a photo op the
two men spoke privately for 40 minutes
the ayatollah reportedly telling the
pope he also believes
christians should be able to live in
peace in iraq and enjoy the same rights
as other iraqis
it's a powerful statement from sustani
who rarely makes his opinions known
when he does shiites in iraq and around
the world
take note
later the pope arrived in the ancient
city of ur
known as the birthplace of abraham the
biblical patriarch revered by christians
muslims and jews a fitting place for an
interfaith meeting
where francis underscored his message
peace does not demand winners or losers
but rather brothers and sisters who for
all the misunderstandings and hurts of
the past
are journeying from conflict to unity
in praying for peace in the middle east
the pope singled out syria
ravaged by a decade of civil war and he
condemned religious extremists who used
terrorism to achieve
their aims
on sunday pope francis will see
firsthand the destruction left behind by
the terrorist islamic state
when he visits the group's former
stronghold in the northern iraqi city
of mosul
the pilgrim of peace as pope francis
called himself
is aware of the risks he's taking amid
an ongoing pandemic
and a regional conflict
this is an emblematic trip and it is my
duty to a martyred land
but he is not traveling alone he is
protected by one of the largest security
deployments in recent iraqi history
10 000 personnel by some estimates
including special forces
24-hour drone surveillance and
undercover intelligence officers
it's the first visit by a pope to iraq
and comes just two days after a rocket
attack
that seemed to put the trip in doubt
his first remarks in baghdad
acknowledged the difficult days most
iraqis have had to endure
without a military escort
over the past several decades iraq has
suffered the disastrous effects of
wars the scourge of terrorism and
sectarian conflicts often grounded
in a fundamentalism incapable of
accepting the peaceful coexistence
of different ethnic and religious groups
the name of god cannot be used to
justify acts of murder
exile terrorism and depression
for over two decades now sectarian
conflict has driven most of iraq's
christians out of the country
in 2014 the so-called islamic state
began
targeting christians driving hundreds of
thousands more from their homes
the pope's visit is a symbol of victory
over this tide of violence
this cathedral in baghdad was the site
of a 2010 terrorist attack
the pope's visit there drew strong
reactions from the community
we feel indescribable joy not only me
but everyone
seeing pope francis in iraq as a
historic event
i'm joined now by journalist owen
holdaway who's in iraq following the
pope's visit
oh and the pope has met with the grand
ayatollah ali
al-sistani why is that meeting so
significant
i think because of the weight sistani
actually has within
iraq he's essentially the head of the
largest community community the sheer
community of iraq
i think the fact that they're being a
dialogue between the two of them is is
extremely important also the leader also
sustained itself he's very reclusive and
rarely gives
political or public statements so i
think the fact that they both also
reiterated the need for
you know being one one united iraq and
all iraqis
regardless of faith um are are or should
live together in peace i think that
really emphasizes and really has
a lot of weight within the country and
also within the right wider middle east
what about non-christians so how are
they reacting to the pope's visit
i mean very much so i mean i think
they're very very happy that the fact
that they're showcasing a different side
of iraq
iraq tends to be thought of you know as
a very sectarian country with a lot of
conflict between the different ethnic
groups
you know be that sunni shia kurd yazidi
um
whomever however i think the showcasing
of the fact of the pope and his first
trip to come
to um to to a foreign country before uh
since the since the pandemic shows that
you know that the iraq iraq is
is is is not not not not the kind of
violent violent a violent country that
is always it's always perceived to be
yeah indeed what can we expect for the
rest of the pope's visit
rest of today and in the next two days
well he went to the city of er
immediately after that and which is
quite symbolic as well because that's
well the founding place of all the all
the three major religions
uh abraham abraham's supposed birthplace
of that he's said to then
uh hold mass within uh back in baghdad
um following that he is then going to
come up to look up to urbia where up
where i'm at currently at the moment
and then go into mosul and visit some
very historic sites there and then also
head to the town of
uh karakosh where he will also visit a
church that was um
significantly attacked by isis uh when
when they when they when they controlled
the area
and then finally culminates his trip uh
being in irby or holding a map holding
and holding them holding an event at the
football stadium here now this is
obviously historic
uh and a very big first step but what
can the pope realistically achieve as
far as
interfaith dialogue goes in the country
i mean he's not going to be able to
disarm all the major groups and major
militias and and he's certainly not
going to be able to stop
some of the violence that's you know
some isis obviously is still operating
in certain areas of this country
and you know here in the bill the us
base was recently attacked by some
sheer militias so obviously he's not
going to be able to end that but i think
particularly the
message that came out of the meeting
with sistani does show that you know
that more that are on a cultural level
on a communitarian level maybe not on a
political level
that there is a unity between the
different different sects and different
different uh groups within this country
and so it's a very powerful message that
i think is putting forward for the
country
and that that itself will also have a
strong political weight against the lead
against the
different political leaders who may who
may want to use you still may want to go
down the sectarian
route all right journalist owen holdaway
speaking to us from urbel in iraq thank
you very much
you